RICH HYNDMAN: Android Developer
office hours.
With me today, little, fluffy
Android as always.
For the first time, Stephan
Linzner is joining us.
He's joined our team from
Stuttgart, Germany?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah,
actually Frankfurt.
But I'm originally coming
from Stuttgart.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, yeah.
He's come over and he's
joined our team.
He'll be based out of the
London office as well.
And so, welcome Stephan.
Bring some new testing skills
to our team that we quite
badly need for all those
questions on
testing that you asked.
So in the future, moderators for
these feel free to answer
more questions on testing.
And hopefully Stephen will be
able to fill in the blanks
where we didn't have that
experience before.
Also, of course, is--
MATT GAUNT: Matthew
Gaunt, hello.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi.
Nick Butcher.
RICH HYNDMAN: Always.
And we've got two
people joined us
in the Hangout already.
We've got Bill and Clemens.
Hi guys.
Thanks for joining us.
NICK BUTCHER: And Chris
Banes is out sick.
So get well soon, Chris.
Because you're clearly
watching.
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
Mystery viewers-- he might
be one of them.
All right.
As usual, we'll be discussing
Android development topics.
But we won't be discussing
roadmap features that haven't
been released.
That sort of thing.
Someone else has just joined
us in the Hangout.
It's Johan.
Hey, Johan.
Good seeing you again.
Thank you for joining
us today.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Hey, Johan.
RICH HYNDMAN: Johan is either
on mute or his laptop is
trying to catch up.
There we go.
A wave from Johan.
OK.
Before we delve into the
moderator, does anyone have
any questions from the
Hangout for us?
Ah, it's Guiseppe as well.
Hey, Guiseppe.
Good to see you.
Any questions for inside
the Hangout today?
BILL MOTE: I have a
question for you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hi, Bill.
BILL MOTE: The AsyncTask went
from being single threaded to
then being parallel
processed and then
back to single threaded.
Why did you do that?
RICH HYNDMAN: Because
it broke stuff.
A lot of people--
NICK BUTCHER: It was never
actually documented, was it,
how it was executed?
So we felt it was OK to change
the implementation because we
weren't actually violating any
contracts that we've made.
But yeah, essentially, because
it broke stuff.
RICH HYNDMAN: People were
relying on the fact that
AsyncTasks would come back in
the order that they were
requested it.
And as soon as we said it's a
multi-threader, this time
coming back in other orders,
applications across the place
all started to fail.
So we did revert it back again
which makes life particularly
awkward for you.
But you can specify.
So you can put the threadpull
executor specified in your
AsyncTask if you'd like it to
be multithreaded or not--
if you like it not to
be multithreaded.
And we always recommend
specifying which one you
prefer, because behavior
may vary.
Behavior definitely will vary.
NICK BUTCHER: Go execute
on executer.
RICH HYNDMAN: Execute
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that's
what you want.
BILL MOTE: We were having a
debate about that yesterday.
And I did a bunch of reading.
So I thought, well, I'll join
the Hangout and ask.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's
a good question.
We've had that one in
conferences before as well.
It's just one of those things.
We do test a lot of applications
with each release
of Android.
And we didn't spot this
particular issue arising.
But it was the early Honeycomb
right, that it
got switched over?
STEPHAN LINZNER:
And sometimes--
sometimes it's also
about performance.
If you have one thread, it might
be faster than spawning
multiple threads.
Because I've seen applications
where they respond like 20 to
40 threads especially when
scrolling a list view.
Just as an addition.
MATT GAUNT: That's what
threadpulls are for.
RICH HYNDMAN: The reason it
happened at that time, as
well, it was all single core
devices up until then.
And then we got the
dual core devices.
So we're like, let's
make use of it.
Let's make all these
applications multicore web.
Oops.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Who else
has just joined us?
We've got Yossi.
Hey, Yossi.
Good to see you in the
Hangout again.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi, guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey, hey.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi.
RICH HYNDMAN: Any other
questions from inside the
Hangout before we have
a look at today's
moderator and G+ thread.
NICK BUTCHER: I'll also
just chip in as well.
I think we had a bit of
discussion on the new format
which we tried out for the
first time last week
compressing us down to half an
hour and trying to keep us
really focused on the content.
And there were some
people saying it
felt a little rushed.
And I'm sorry if that
came across.
But also, a lot of people seemed
to very much enjoy it.
Especially looking at the
YouTube stats, people seem to
have got a lot more from that.
So we're going to stick with
the half hour format.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes,
it's unfortunate.
The people who interact with us
in the Hangout really seem
to appreciate the
time to chat.
Thank you to the guys
who do join us.
You do make half the
show for us.
But the stats are
just incredible.
NICK BUTCHER: But the 5,000 or
so rewatches on YouTube seem
to prefer the shorter format.
RICH HYNDMAN: We've done shows
now, 1 hour, 45 minutes, and
30 minutes-- and the shorter
show, the more of the show
people watch, not just
percentage wise but actually
in real minutes.
So by the time we get
to an hour show, it
drops quite a bit.
NICK BUTCHER: So we're
optimizing now to give minutes.
RICH HYNDMAN: The whole show
will be five minutes, and
everyone will watch
the whole thing.
Which is sorta like Reto does
on "This Week in Android"
which was so fast this week,
I haven't even seen it yet.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, nor did I.
RICH HYNDMAN: Reto?
OK, anything else from
inside the Hangout?
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Can I
ask a question quick?
RICH HYNDMAN: Are Nexus
10s unbreakable?
Let me find out.
It is fine, yup.
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Can I go?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes,
please proceed.
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Yes.
We are implementing a new
application that is based on
the module concept.
For module concept, I mean that
to the base application
must be able to load external
library in JAR.
I would like to ask if there
is any suggestion from you
guys how to implement a good
management of external model?
So the user would be able, for
example, paying through the
In-app system some special
model, and once he paid, then
we would supply the download
link of the JAR library.
And then, the app would
be able to load at
runtime this model.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hm.
MATT GAUNT: What's
the question?
So what's--
RICH HYNDMAN: Whether
it's possible--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATT GAUNT: I think
with both--
RICH HYNDMAN: So Britta did a
post on Android Developers
about ClassLoader and loading
classes remotely at some
point, didn't we?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: It was Fred?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, OK.
Fred, Britta-- interchangable.
So yeah, you asked whether it's
technically possible or
the best way to do it?
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: The
best way to do it.
RICH HYNDMAN: So the only
written guidance we have on
that I'm aware of at the
moment is on Android
Developer's blog.
I'll find it for you now.
That was a post written by Fred
Chung, apparently, which
does go into details of the
best way to do dynamically
load class files.
But other than that, Android
Developers' blogspot.
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: And connected
question, what do
you think about the permission
security--
the permission security will be
connected inside, would we
attach it to do the single
library that we load at
runtime, or all the permissions
must be in the
main application?
RICH HYNDMAN: Definitely all
permissions must be in the
main application.
There's no other
way than that.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Specify
them once.
You cannot change that.
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Definitely?
RICH HYNDMAN: Definitely.
NICK BUTCHER: Or for a different
example, if they're
in a plug in system, you can
look at the dashclock that
Roman Nurik just opensourced
which has an API where you can
kind of write your own modules
and runtime will pull them in.
So that's an example code
you could probably take
a little look at.
So that's at code.google.com/p
for "project" dashclock.
And technically--
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: And we can
put this link in the chart?
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, no.
RICH HYNDMAN: We can put it
into a G+ thread, right?
NICK BUTCHER: I'll put
it in your ears.
MATT GAUNT: I'll do it.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: I will.
I was just joking.
RICH HYNDMAN: I've posted our
link into the G+ thread for
this Hangout.
For the class loading.
And Nick will do the
other one for you.
And everyone looking
for it right now.
Good question.
And should I have Ron or
[INAUDIBLE] do it?
I've
NICK BUTCHER: Not yet--
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: By the time
that you find it, I would add
something, Richard.
Well, I was just trying
to find the solution.
Because I was thinking that
the permission could be
included in the single JAR and
not in the single library, and
not in the main one.
But at the handle for the day,
if I have to include the
permissions in the manifest in
the main application I'm in,
then this would not solve the
whole other real problem.
Because the real problem today
is that I would like to have
specific feeders that users
can buy separately.
And then, when he buy
separately, he know that this
special feature need some
special permission.
That is the real problem.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, so there's
two solutions to that.
The filters list on
the Android--
oh my god, I have to drink-- on
the Play store themselves,
just list the filters
as separate
purchases on the Play store.
And they can have their
own permissions.
And link to them from inside
your application.
The other thing would be
downloading APKs to the
device, and then calling the
installer to install those
APKs and then show the
permission screen.
But that wouldn't be allowed if
you were shipping after the
Play store.
So the only way would be to--
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Could you
please explain better the
second solution?
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, the second
solution doesn't really apply.
Because it would be effectively
writing your own
marketplace where you would
download APK files, and then
call the device's installer
to install them.
And then, the user would get
to accept the permissions.
But you're not allowed to ship
other marketplaces inside the
Play store.
So it wouldn't really apply.
The only way to have separate
permissions is to have--
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Do you think
possible that in future
we will have optional
admissions?
RICH HYNDMAN: As per the
disclaimer at the start of the
show, we wouldn't gamble as
to answer that question.
I don't know.
No idea, Guiseppe.
No idea.
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: But this
is a question that must be
brought to the main place
where they decide?
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
GUISEPPE PORCELLI: Because
optional permissions-- some
option permissions will
help us to [INAUDIBLE]
and many customers
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: My team are
fully aware of it.
We know that [INAUDIBLE]
has implemented it.
And it has been discussed.
But there's nothing to talk
about on future releases,
unfortunately either way.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, let's get
back to the moderated
questions and try and
get through them.
So a few of them popped up.
And a few more are coming
in as we speak.
First quick one, slightly off
topic, but where do you get
the Android heart t-shirt?
RICH HYNDMAN: This is a beta
bean, sorry, a jellybean.
MATT GAUNT: It's a jellybean.
RICH HYNDMAN: If there were
two little things
it'd be more obvious.
NICK BUTCHER: And you get one
by having a time machine and
working on the Android
engineering team.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, they went
out to everyone who worked on
the Jelly Bean project
unfortunately.
No, fortunately.
NICK BUTCHER: So you have
those then [INAUDIBLE]
unlucky.
RICH HYNDMAN: Or take a photo
of this and get one printed.
Also a good one here from
Andrew Kelly, a
friend of the show--
not directly related to Android,
but is there a way to
change the private channel
graphic that appears in the
Google Play store.
I don't know about the answer.
STEPHAN LINZNER: I got asked
the same question.
Maybe it was you.
I was just issuing an email to
the guys, and I will get back
at you with our answer.
We don't know yet if
it's possible.
It's not in the documents.
I looked it up.
But we will get back
at you for that.
So next up, Mackan from Sweden
asks, how do you open a custom
file type from a Gmail app?
If I make an intent filter for
application/octet-stream and a
file pattern like .mab, it still
tries to open all other
file types as well as my app,
like file.epub, etc.
RICH HYNDMAN: So all other file
types as well as my app?
MATT GAUNT: I don't
see that last bit.
RICH HYNDMAN: We've had
this question in--
NICK BUTCHER: So basically
saying if you just say that
your app can handle all
octet-streams, then it will--
yeah, it's too wide.
It'll open other types, not just
the type that you want.
Yeah, there is a way
to specify this
that is quite specific.
Who did a post on
this recently?
Anyone offhand?
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
MATT GAUNT: No.
RICH HYNDMAN: You're right.
There was something
that recently.
NICK BUTCHER: I can't
remember offhand.
Talk amongst yourselves while
I look for something.
General [INAUDIBLE]
question.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm back to
the Android tshirt.
Just bare with us a second while
we all stare at screens
momentarily.
MATT GAUNT: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: Talk amongst
yourselves.
MATT GAUNT: What I'll do is I'll
go on to other questions
that came in on the Google+
stream from Jens Hohl.
Any suggestions on creating
a floating
window on top of fragments?
So it depends kind of what
you're trying to do
it with that one.
But my gut instinct would be
it kind of sounds like you
want to just have something
in a relative layer or the
activity layer.
And then, essentially, add the
fragments within that and just
make sure that the window
element is kind of the last
thing in the relative layout.
So it's kind of floating
on top.
If you can kind of give us some
more context if that's
not suitable may
be a good idea.
But ultimately it kind
of sounds like
what you want to do.
And a floating window, I'm
assuming you're not trying to
[INAUDIBLE] inside an app
in an actual window, in
which case-- no.
But yeah, that's what I'd do.
[INAUDIBLE] the activity
there.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, you could
actually do a download and
customize it.
That would be another
way of doing it.
RICH HYNDMAN: My initial
reaction would be [INAUDIBLE].
But if you could--
but if by floating, he means he
wants to be able to move it
around as well or that
he just wants--
MATT GAUNT: You could do
an activity with just a
transparent background and
then have a little chunk.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You could track touch inputs.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: And I make
the window around?
MATT GAUNT: Different options.
Yeah, what you're trying to
do, I guess would be--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, James, if
you have any more details on
exactly what you're trying to
do, just put them on the
thread and we'll see them.
And we'll see if we can get
you a more precise answer.
MATT GAUNT: I'm all
about precision.
Anyone find any more info
on the [INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: Nick's deep
in his [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEPHAN LINZNER: There is an
answer on state or flow, but
not exactly what he asked.
So I think we have
to look at some.
RICH HYNDMAN: You know,
unfortunately we didn't get a
chance to read through the
moderator questions before the
show today due to Chris Bane's
unexpected illness.
So we're slightly
less prepared.
Guiseppe, could you--
Yes, Guiseppe I put the link
for that dynamic library
loading in the Google+
thread for this post.
So if you go to Google+ where
it says, you'll see my name
and the link there.
Not a problem.
Weibe, who's usually inside the
Hangout with us but not
today, says, good
to see Stephan.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Wasn't--
and he says he could
post some code.
Anything else?
Do we have any other questions
for inside the Hangout?
We're kind of short
on material.
Or anything you just
want to talk about?
MATT GAUNT: Well, Johan just
had the thing with the
[INAUDIBLE]
now dodgy Android user group.
You guys have become--
STEPHAN LINZNER: And you might
want to talk about it, about
the Android Puzzles project?
MATT GAUNT: That as well.
They just signed a bit of
paper which makes them.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Sure.
Sure.
Well, first of all,
boys, welcome.
Stephan, good to see you
there in London.
We registered as an official
foundation now, and it's good,
so we can now more easily get
some funds from companies.
And we have some great Meetups
lined up, so one is the Code
Puzzlers and tips and tricks.
We're going to do a couple
of workshops as well.
We're going to do something
on design, so a
couple of good Meetups.
Yeah.
And a little party because
we're, well, an official
foundation, so parties
are always good.
RICH HYNDMAN: What is an
official foundation as opposed
to [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHAN PELGRIM: Oh, just register
with the Chamber of
Commerce and tax office.
So we've been doing mainly--
how do you say it-- small
Meetups, but some sent their
prices involved and large
catering stuff.
And it's easier to do it
officially, so we can do
better Meetups then.
RICH HYNDMAN: The Dutch
Android users are very
business [INAUDIBLE] as a
company in its own right.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thank you, Nick.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
NICK BUTCHER: So I found
a good link.
I'll placed a link to
it in the G+ thread.
But it's basically saying that
you need to register for both
your application type and
the octet-stream.
It sounds like you're doing the
right thing by listening
for application [INAUDIBLE]
stream.
But you're also providing the
host and path pattern as well
is the bit that we don't
quite specify.
I'm just trying to reread it.
So isn't there a [INAUDIBLE]
like just .map like I think you
actually need to specify.
I think the problem of it you're
not specifying the path
pattern correctly.
I think you need to do .star
and then escape the dot.
And then Map.
So rather than just .map as your
path pattern, it needs to
be dot.star/.map I think
is the problem there.
You're not specify the path
pattern, which is why it's
appearing [INAUDIBLE].
It's a RegEx thing.
I will post a link to
reply [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: tuxjsmith or
tuxjssmith, probably
tuxjsmith, [INAUDIBLE]
from the UK has asked a
question about account
[INAUDIBLE].
Some users Galaxy S2 and ZTE
that he knows about are unable
to register with the Google
Cloud Messaging service when
using his chat app.
Missing Google accounts
firewalls blocking so ports
have been ruled out.
Can you think of
other reasons?
That's a tricky one.
Why wouldn't GCM be available
on these devices?
Obviously, not having internet
connection, firewalls--
missing Google accounts would've
been the first one I
would have thought of.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Problem with Play
Store caching maybe on
the device?
RICH HYNDMAN: The Google
Cloud Messaging?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Play services?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't know.
Usually--
I mean if people are installing
the applications
through the Play Store, the Play
Store is up to date, and
the Play services will
be up to date.
MATT GAUNT: Could be an issue
with switching from the
previous [INAUDIBLE]
cloud messaging.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Maybe the update
that you send doesn't
work for those devices?
RICH HYNDMAN: Galaxy S2 though
is hugely widespread.
We'd know if there were
big issues on it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
I can say we don't have issues
here with Galaxy
S2 or ZTE with GCM.
RICH HYNDMAN: And it's
just some of them.
I think again, unfortunately in
this case, you're going to
have to get more info, either
put some more logging inside
your application or find a
reproducible test case.
Get in contact with one of the
people who have told you that
their applications-- the
application's spinning on
their device.
I have [INAUDIBLE], and
I reach out to my
users pretty much--
[PHONE RINGING]
when I need help debugging
things like this.
It's probably best
just to do that.
See if they can send you any
screenshots of the situation.
Maybe you'll notice there's
something wrong with the
network connectivity
or who knows.
It's a strange one though.
It'll be nice to find
out what it was.
M@rine of Hell is back again.
Hi, M@rine of Hell.
What's the best way to flag
a version with increased
functionality to separate it
from the commercial version
with unlimited use
of functionality?
A version with increased
functionality as opposed to a
commercial version with
unlimited use of
functionality, is there
a best practice?
I don't really want to create
two development branches.
Did you get that?
So you have a standard version,
a version with
increased functionality, and
a commercial versions with
unlimited use?
MATT GAUNT: So maybe it's a
case you can buy one as a
pretrial with limited
functionality.
You can pay a bit of money, you
can get one [INAUDIBLE]--
RICH HYNDMAN: Increased
functionality?
MATT GAUNT: --[INAUDIBLE]
something.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then you can
buy it while subscribing to
the whole thing, the
commercial one?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
So I guess rather than having
three separate apps to do each
of those, you just want to sit
there and say, they've got
this, they've got
this version, or
they've got this version.
RICH HYNDMAN: And who are you
flagging-- is this the flagger
to use it in the Play Store?
Or it's a flagger inside your
code so you can keep one
source tree?
But be able to build three
different versions of it.
If it's one source tree with
three different versions, I'd
be tempted to use a library
project and put everything
that is common inside the
library project and then run
off three separate projects off
the top of it, restricting
the functionality either
into these
three different baskets--
buckets.
Again, more information.
Sorry.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Because presumably if you're
going to have three different
apps in the store, you're
going to have to have
different packages anyway,
so that [INAUDIBLE]
doing makes sense.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: I'd go with a
single app, and different
in-app packages to unlock
some features.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Single app,
single code-base.
RICH HYNDMAN: Or maybe
subscription to--
NICK BUTCHER: -- make it--
RICH HYNDMAN: --the
commercial one.
NICK BUTCHER: --make your
life a lot easier.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: If that's possible
with your setup.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Hopefully, that did answer
your question.
How is the best way to become
an Android developer?
How is the best way--
hey-- hey, there--
end the chat there.
How is the best way to become
an Android developer?
Go to developers.android.com
is definitely
your best way to start.
Download the bundled STK.
It will install the Android
STK and the clips for you.
And then we have a whole bunch
of tutorials, right from
beginner stuff through to
advanced topics, so still
having a look through
the tutorials.
If you're already a Java
developer, you'll find it
ought to be pretty easy.
You just have to get the
UI and sorted out.
And--
yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: And then you see
if there's like an Android
developers Meetup or Google
Technology User Group or
something like this
in your area.
So if you see Google developers
groups in your area
and get to meet some
like-minded
people that will help.
RICH HYNDMAN: There's also
tons of YouTube videos on
becoming an Android
developers.
One guy do a series of 100
YouTube videos which takes you
right from of the
eclipse to being
supposedly an expert developer.
NICK BUTCHER: Wow.
RICH HYNDMAN: And there
lots of other--
NICK BUTCHER: Really.
RICH HYNDMAN: --resources
online.
Check out the activity life
cycle and then everything else
that makes up an Android app
in terms of services--
STEPHAN LINZNER: And we have
great training courses
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You could do a training
course.
STEPHAN LINZNER: And look
at the samples.
The samples are very good.
MATT GAUNT: Read his book is
also a great ones to get
started on.
I forgot what it's called.
But, yeah, read Jeremiah's
book.
It's a good one.
RICH HYNDMAN: But as is always
the way, just get stuck in.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Make your
first Android app--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: --play with it,
get excited about it, run
around with it on your phone.
That's the best thing about a
program for mobile devices,
right, you have it on
you all the time.
You can show it off.
People suggest things.
You go home.
You try them out, and then you
just have good times with it,
and you can't--
you can't stop.
AUDIENCE: I have to disagree.
You'll see that doesn't
look cool.
That looks awful.
STEPHAN LINZNER: What
did he say?
AUDIENCE: I think it's one of
the nicest features you can
have on the device.
MATT GAUNT: Can you
show us-- now that
you're full screen shows?
Say something [INAUDIBLE]
to us.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hey,
can you see this?
Can you see me now?
OK.
Say you're on the screen and you
want to go through all the
applications.
Instead of pressing the Home
button and then trying to get
to the drawer and stuff, you
just swipe to the left, and
you have all the apps,
all the start apps.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is this
an edge gesture?
NICK BUTCHER: What about all
these apps that you use the
Bezel gesture opening the
[INAUDIBLE] trails and things?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No.
It's nice because you can have
recently used apps also
available here and
also start apps.
So if you want--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, but if--
within an application, something
like, say, Spotify,
which has to be swiped from the
edge to open up the tray,
what happened?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Just a second.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is the app
only inactive when the
launch is on script?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
Yeah-- no, no, no.
It's also active like
when I'm on Chrome.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, yeah.
So if I wanted--
RICH HYNDMAN: So if I want to
go to the previous tab on
Chrome, and I do the
edge swipe--
MATT GAUNT: Oh, man.
RICH HYNDMAN: --now I can't get
to the previous tab now?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, you can.
You can.
MATT GAUNT: How?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I'll
open some tabs.
Here, some tabs are open.
I don't know if you
can see them.
Just a second.
RICH HYNDMAN: You have on
the phone, not on the 7.
On the 7 you've got
tabs at top.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Any application
that interfere with the
behavior of other applications
can get barred
from the Play store.
I'm just saying.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: [INAUDIBLE].
I think it's a cool app.
RICH HYNDMAN: It is cool.
The [INAUDIBLE]
functionality.
MATT GAUNT: Each to their own.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's the great
thing about Android, right,
just the functionality you want
on your device you can
make it fit on there.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No,
I didn't do it.
It's a friend of mine on XDA.
I'll send you the link to the
chat or to the G thread, G+
thread, to people to see.
I think it's nice.
It's just to see how you can
learn enable all the cool
gestures and--
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, we're late
in our new 30-minute format.
We are down to the
last two minutes.
So we don't have--
MATT GAUNT: There's one last
question from the moderator.
It should be a quick
and easy one.
Is there a way to use other
languages such as Python as
native development languages
on Android,
asked Burhan from Kuwait.
And the answer is no.
It can only supported route
for native development is
through Java or with the MPK.
There are applications out there
such as the scripting
layer for Android and so on,
which you'll run as an
interpretative language
on your device.
There may be some scripting in
other languages, but they
aren't any routes for having
it compiled native.
There are approaches out there
I think like Mono and stuff
that which were trying to
be cross-compilation.
Well, I think where
it's actually--
NICK BUTCHER: No.
I think it will just take C#
and then compile it down to
[INAUDIBLE] code.
RICH HYNDMAN: MishaS is saying,
can you please,
please, please answer
my question.
I've got a class in
a few minutes.
I need to go.
But--
MATT GAUNT: Maybe he--
RICH HYNDMAN: --answer
his question anyway.
MATT GAUNT: -- he wanted to do
something with embedded text
to speech, but he wanted to
do the offline stuff.
You know before you always had
to connect to the server, and
now there's the ability to do
it on the Android device
itself without having
to go online.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Speech
recognition.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Text-to-speech thing.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Then what
about text to speech?
MATT GAUNT: That would
be the voice
recognition because you'd--
STEPHAN LINZNER: Text to
speech is recognizing.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, yeah,
going the other way.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
So that's the reason why
I've confused it.
And it sounds like you've
confused it as well.
So that might be it.
RICH HYNDMAN: I want to
use offline text to
speech in my app.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Embedded text to speech.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
And you try that and
didn't work.
It should've worked.
If we have a bit more detail.
When did you see the question?
MATT GAUNT: It's further up.
So I'll read it out.
Ohh, went [INAUDIBLE]--
RICH HYNDMAN: Where is it?
We've got one minute, dude.
MATT GAUNT: I know
it was in there.
No, it's--
it's looks like it's actually
disappeared.
That is where.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry,
Misha, I can't see
the question anywhere.
MATT GAUNT: It was in there,
but it's gone.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATT GAUNT: I think we're
sort of wrap this up.
Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: So now--
STEPHAN LINZNER: Thank you
for joining us again.
And join us the same time next
week, and put your questions
into the moderator in order
for [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Go, Yossi, yeah.
[HOOTING]
MATT GAUNT: He's sending us a
link to his horrible, horrible
[INAUDIBLE] like that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, but on his
screen he's showing the
Ultimate Stopwatch.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
gorgeously designed Ultimate
Stopwatch that went
live yesterday.
Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: There
are some bugs.
RICH HYNDMAN: There are
some bugs against it.
NICK BUTCHER: So join us
same time next week.
Thank you very much
for your time.
And don't forget there's the
rest of the Goggle Developers
Live program as well.
So check out the app clinic
on Friday and more
design action next week.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Please get
your questions in
the moderator by--
AUDIENCE: Bye.
NICK BUTCHER: --every Monday.
Thanks very much.
RICH HYNDMAN: Bye.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Bye, guys.
Thanks for everything.